support booth University in the
production of more videos by visiting
the link in the description below where
you'll find more details thank you and
enjoy
so Rutherford's nuclear model was a good
step forward but there was a problem
with it what that problem was is that it
didn't account for the atoms entire mass
so that's kind of where James Chadwick
came in he ended up discovering the
neutron which is a neutral subatomic
particle with approximately the same
mass as a proton how'd he do it well he
set up an alpha emitter to launch alpha
particles alpha particles at beryllium
of course alpha particles we've seen
them before they have a plus two charge
we saw them in Rutherford's cold foil
experiment when these alpha particles
hit the beryllium they knocked out
high-energy radiation high-energy
radiation that had no charge so that was
kind of interesting it's especially
interesting that this high-energy
radiation that came out of this
beryllium when it came into contact with
paraffin wax it would knock protons out
of the paraffin wax so the question
really was what is this high-energy
radiation with no charge and the initial
thought was that gamma rays that's a
little bit ugly let me try that again
there we go gamma rays projected out of
the beryllium gamma rays are very very
high-energy rays the gamma particles are
essentially have no mass so this
couldn't be correct this was wrong
because they're not massive at all
because we're talking about a particle
coming into contact with this paraffin
wax and knocking a proton loose okay so
it can be a gamma ray or a gamma
particle because they're too tiny
they're effectively massless so there
had to have been something that was
large enough or massive enough to knock
these protons loose so and I also had to
have no charge right so it couldn't have
been these alpha particles because the
gamma particles are positively too
charged
so let me draw an analogy here if we
have a ping-pong ball being launched at
a bowling ball really really fast is
this ping-pong ball gonna get this
bowling ball to move probably not right
ping-pong balls are very very very light
they don't really they're not densely
packed with mass and it wouldn't really
face a bowling ball they're super super
massive and dense that's kind of the
situation with the gamma particle or
gamma ray and proton there's no way a
gamma rays gonna knock a proton how to
knock a proton into moving right so this
thing is not going to move forward or be
launched in any direction if a bowling
ball is going to be knocked loose then
you might have to have something that
has a mass that's pretty similar to it
and so that's when Chadwick thought that
there is likely to be a neutral particle
in the nucleus of an atom with the same
or similar mass to a proton that would
be basically this the idea of a bowling
ball being shot at another bowling ball
to knock that bullet that that bowling
ball forward this could happen right you
can imagine that because they have
around the same mass right two bowling
balls probably have around the same mass
so the conclusion that Chadwick made
that's high energy radiation with no
charge was actually neutrons which are
denoted like this and zero sometimes
we'll see more about that later so its
conclusion was that there are neutral
particles neutrons with a mass nearly
identical to protons contained in the
atomic nucleus so when you think about
that and the nuclear model basically can
have neutrons as part of the as part of
the nuclear model right neutrons in
there in the atomic nucleus along with
the protons so this would account for
the entire mass of the atom which solves
the problem that rough
purrs model had now I do want to know
that this is not actually the the how
the model looked at the time of
Chadwicks discovery of the neutron Niels
Bohr had he had presented his model of
the Bohr model which could electron
orbits so it wouldn't have looked
wouldn't look exactly like this at the
time but I'm just I'm created this based
simply on the idea that if Rutherford's
model was had the knowledge of Chadwicks
model just kind of added on to it then
this would be the model of the atom but
at the time Niels Bohr has his own thing
we'll talk more about Niels Bohr later I
think anyway I hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching you found
that video helpful be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more content also follow
move university on the different social
media links in the description below
thank you and happy studying